A Japanese company can help you soak in the sights of Florence and Rome...
...without ever leaving your city.
A Tokyo entertainment company, First Airlines, is offering virtual travel experiences...
...to customers grounded due to the coronavirus pandemic,...
...and the experience you'll receive is just like the one you would receive on an actual flight.
Customers, I mean passengers, sit in first class seats in a mock airplane cabin.
For starters, they're given a full-fledged pre-flight safety demonstration...
...with a life vest and oxygen mask.
Monitors in the front of the cabin show views of the aircraft taking off.
They are served in-flight meals and drinks just like they would on a real flight,...
...all while enjoying views of passing clouds and scenery...
...that are projected onto the sides of the cabin.
For a more immersive experience, passengers can even opt to wear virtual reality goggles...
...and get an actual sense of seeing things.
They can tour popular destinations like Paris, New York, Rome and Hawaii,...
...all while being seated in the cabin.
But if you can't wait till then to fly to your favorite destination,...
...you now know where to go.